is no other organization i think in the
nfl that is about their mantra of always
compete that pete carroll
has that phrase up there in seattle
always compete he brought it from usc
because you never know if you if you
compete you have a shot at a job with
the seattle seahawks obviously
competition is revered in all
corners of the nfl no question about it
but with john schneider and pete carroll
it's true this organization truly is
about it look at russell wilson right
and we had
um tyler lockett on last week
that's right and we talked about hey
you're a third round pick
from kansas state and
do you take any inspiration being a
third round selection and blossoming
in this lineup in the same way that your
quarterback does
and then our next guest chris brockman
was a seventh round selection
226 in the 2017 nfl draft
and i decided to look up who got drafted
did the seahawks have another pick after
david moore
in the seventh round of that draft and
they did 249th overall they chose chris
carson
wow
how's that working out that's working
out right
and fresh off of his team finishing up
another exhilarating contest for the
entire country that's
on the edge of their seat watching for
the 5-0 seahawks david moore here on the
rich eisen show how are you david
i'm doing pretty good how you doing i am
doing fine where were you on that draft
night
seventh round sitting there waiting for
your phone to ring i
imagine um where were you that night
man i was honestly uh at my house in
kansas texas and my parents
quite a bit of people there my whole
coming out of east central right that's
where you were coming out of
at the time and so you're sitting around
and though
pete carroll calls your phone you got a
206 phone call from a 206 area code or
something like that
i'm like the obviously didn't even have
my phone on me it was in there on the
charger in my room
and my sister's in there and she brought
it to me on mute
so i honestly didn't know what was going
on i was honestly just talking to myself
and it's kind of
i know what was when i heard pete
talking but i'm like why did i hear me
no i'm just like all baffled
and then i finally figured out something
yeah and then my heart dropped so your
your phone was handed to you by your
sister on mute
and pete's like are you there like
literally
and you're like trapped me is that
really what
happened back oh
my gosh but then then you show up right
and now
uh your coach is pete carroll your
quarterback is russell wilson
and he's looking at you and i'm sure he
told you right you have a chance
correct he literally had that
conversation with you i'm sure
for sure what was it like walk me
through what that conversation was
for you i was he starts off as meeting
though tom with the whole
always compete you're either competing
or you're not and uh
once once we got out of a rookie mini
camp
it was just like he was talking to me
and then
he had a son which is our receiver coach
and he was talking to me and they're
just like
you go out there and you just be
yourself
just do what you always done don't be
extra don't do nothing new
just go out there and have fun and just
play at your best just be the best you
you can be every day
compete every day against yourself and
good things happen for you and then
i tried to live my daylight on my days
and day out like that and
good things ended up happening so what's
it like being in the huddle
with russell wilson in a game like last
night with the game on the line
uh you get an opportunity from your
defense uh you got to go 94 yards
one time out remaining to win the
football game and driving rain what was
that like
what's it like kind of like practice he
comes in
he is real chill real calm and he's like
hey
we uh we got this fellas we just got we
got to go out there
we're going to do it we're going to
finish it stay poor
stay poised and he'll call it play and
then
he keeps us calm and we all keep each
other calm so
that's one thing that i think that's
pretty big in moments like
last night for sure big games and then
coming down to the nitty-gritty like
that
heck yeah trying to stay calm is the
best way and having somebody like that
one of your leaders
keeping you calm yeah that helps out a
lot
i'm sure it does so honestly his his
demeanor does not change and nobody
else's changes from like you're sitting
there
um you know in that beautiful spot that
you have your practice facility that
that
that that doesn't change at all it's the
same
no not at all and sometimes
to keep it the same me and dk and tyler
come and start playing we'll be laughing
at something
just something that makes us laugh
something that we laughed about earlier
during the day
just to keep us kind of like
not so nervous not so thinking about
what's gonna happen but
staying happy at the same time did that
happen
did that happen last night david did
that happen
like what can you walk me through what
you were laughing about to keep calm in
that crucial situation that turned into
a fifth win
for you i'm trying to think sometimes do
we honestly just be laughing at like
each other if somebody's like really it
just depends on what what's going on
what's going on that night or what's
going on in the huddle
but we'll just start laughing and that's
when russ comes in and that's right
that's when you got to pull it together
that is amazing david moore
the seattle seahawks here on the rich
eisen show so
um you're six foot 215 that's what
you're listed
what is it like to be standing next to
dk metcalf
shoot
i don't know have you ever stood beside
them kind of i bet we'd be
the same we'd be thinking the same big
dude
my god lee i wonder what it's like
to be that tall on top of that
that swole and then moving like that
huh that'd be a little dangerous i
wonder what what i could do with that
but
you know i'm with my little six for 215.
hey no i'll make board i know you're
doing your thing um
dk uh i mean that was a hell of a play
and a hell of a catch
what was your perspective of that last
night david
uh usually during times like that i know
it's for sure probably gonna go to him
and
just knowing who dk is what kind of
player he is
i kind of figured something happened and
he's gonna have to make a play for sure
and knowing dk he does that every week
and he does it practice day in day out
he goes in
always trying to do the best the most
spectacular thing so
he pushes himself and we push each other
the fact that you got a player like that
at the end of the game you know you can
trust
you can rely on him that's pretty big
and he'll make him going after making
that big catch that was huge to see
and i was very happy for him i was so
pumped
i was in the space soon as he got up off
the ground i feel like
what was it like in the locker room
after the game sir
what was that like very energetic
we was uh kind of waiting on russ and dk
to get back in from talking outside
but as soon as they came in oh it's kind
of like a party honestly
the music was raising everybody felt
like they was raising
and i'm trying to get the tape off
but at the same time trying to party so
yeah i was always all over the place
it's a good environment for sure well i
mean it just seems like again
um you guys win in the most thrilling
fashion we all know what happened
uh with you uh and your team against new
england stopping cam newton
at the very end but it was your
touchdown that
put your team on top to stay that night
and it just seems that it's just
somebody contributing something or other
to keep this team
undefeated uh where what conversations
do you have about how far you can go in
this
this season david uh
i would say we have conversations saying
like we can go as far as we can
as far as we want to go as far as we
want to take it it just all depends on
us
how we come in and prepare
how we come in and want to grind and how
we
i don't know how we want to be the best
team in nfc and then
in general just being the best team
just trying to win the super bowl but uh
that's our main focus is
just taking a game after game and
knowing that we all have one
end goal and that's to make it to the
big show
and winning it so we try to
i would say uh not really think too much
about it
but just live in
the present and let the future play
itself out
just keep coming in and doing what you
always do
never really changing up keeping the
same routine
and try to hope for the best
and you guys are 5-0 now and david i
appreciate the phone call here
sir uh congrats on that w on um
and let's uh let's stay in touch down
down the line here
on this program i appreciate that that
sounds good to me
absolutely david thanks for the call uh
you take care of yourself and
um and congrats on everything that's
happening in your career you're a
self-made individual
and uh you deserve all the accolades i
really appreciate that thank you
you got it it's david moore here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here